welcome back to game sports coverage of
e3 2017 I'm Lucy and joining myself and
Pete today is Cliff Bleszinski good to
see you guys yeah thank you for joining
us
absolutely thanks for having me I like
the setup it feels like Sky News yes
exactly
what we're going for absolutely although
except when the lights are on we look
like the council from XCOM yeah yeah
yeah ominous yeah thanks for joining us
how's your III going so far the first
full day it's going well it's it's a
really exciting year for myself in the
studio so the history going back to the
last time that I launched a new IP
intellectual property world whatever you
want to call it was like ten years ago
with the first Gears of War and at e3
the ultimate sign of a publisher getting
behind you is the banner yes like hey I
joke you like if your publisher actually
believes in what they're doing they will
spend the ton of money and actually
print out an enormous bit of key art on
the side of the convention center and
law breakers has that this year and I
first heard that we were going to do it
a couple months ago and then we went
through and I helped approve the key art
for it and to come around the corner and
to see a new IP next to all these
established ones far cry 5 like the
entire size of the Convention Center and
you know Marvel vs. Capcom all these
things you know Call of Duty World War 2
you see all this existing brands and
then here's little old defined cliff and
boskie saying no like you know we're
going to give you some new stuff because
gamers say they want new stuff and it's
the same thing with film and TV right
yeah like I want new things and then
it's like no I just
South Park remember Barry's I just want
to go back to the first you know what
new things are scary I want to go back
to what I know and so you know it takes
you a monumental effort to kind of get
in people's face and it requires off on
a 50-foot by 50-foot banner attached to
the side of the Convention Center I mean
I mean that I mean like YouTube as well
like your new CGI trailer is all over
YouTube it's like every ad that I'm
getting yeah I'm sorry
that's good it's a good trailer well my
favorite pub that I went to one day so
when I first had the trailer on my phone
I'd show it to like friends and family
people who I trusted the occasional like
you know service industry friend hey
check this out oh my god that's really
cool
you don't just hang out at the barn
occasionally drink you actually do
things throughout the day and so then
the trailer came together and then one
of the bartenders I know is like hey
your games on my phone now that the
trailer is live and our publisher Nexon
has been doing a really really good job
of supporting us with mark
spend when we did the alpha way back I
gotta kidding remembers a while back
they didn't really spend a lot of money
to raise awareness which we were really
frustrated at the time but in hindsight
the Alpha was so bare-bones and it was
so just kind of a it was only four main
ways to play the game eight characters a
handful of maps that look decent but
they didn't look great and then the team
really started kind of you know as a
look as a locomotive engine just really
get going and get and kind of get moving
and then we really gelled and so now you
know we're going to be shipping with
nine different roles eighteen characters
of course because it's law versus
breakers and more to come yeah well you
said you've been around for a while I
know that and I'm very curious about
your perspective on how your
relationship with your fans has maybe
evolved not yours in particular but the
relationship between developers and fans
in general yeah well I mean first off
when you look at the business there's a
whole situation where your average
publisher doesn't want the fans even
knowing what the team is much less the
individuals because it's the publishers
best interest to treat game development
is kind of a factory where as everything
is in place and interchangeable and I
being from a theater background back in
the day and maybe from not being popular
in high school that would decide that I
was going to be known for making video
games and oh it was you know fearless
about putting myself out there for
better for worse in many many times and
now we're at the point where I mean kind
of like this other face of my life with
bosky and kind of being here and in you
know growing a beard which these are a
lot of work by the way nobody told me
that like if you don't want to do the
full neckbeard you got to keep that
thing trim and everything it's it's
really a lot of work and you know
they're starting to say hello again at
these conventions whereas I was starting
to fade into obscurity kind of like in
fact the future when like the timelines
change to everything like that and I
realize like you know like I always said
I got this business to make great games
to make some money doing it to be known
for it I do really enjoy being visible
and people stopping and saying oh my god
I love this or you're my inspiration and
it's we're in the New World Order of
these influencers as I mentioned when I
ran into you the other day three full
days of having you know these really
sweet awesome charismatic YouTube and
twitch kids come out and one of them
puts his hand on my arm he goes my dad's
a big fan of yours oh it's like the
biggest light I'm like I mean to be fair
I'm I mean I'm 42 but I started at 17
right so what you're seeing is like a
cross-generational element of the work
that I've worked on where people are
digging it and so
at the end of the day I put my arm in
his shoulder and I said I hope you'll be
a fan of mine now right and if I you
know if this industry doesn't kill me
maybe your son or daughter will
eventually be a fan but I just I missed
this the spectacle of it all you know I
realized walking into the Convention
Center I woke up this morning I'm like
oh here we go again because I decided in
between the influencer event and e3 to
take the family to Disneyland which is
wonderful but Disneyland is another
thing that just you know I slept so
amazing that night it just hit the
sheets and passed the hell out for eight
hours I'm like God we doing this again
and like that little like you know like
little cliffie be on my shoulders like
okay you love this stuff right and then
just kind of came in and saw the setup
and saw that already after the show
floor doors had opened that we had a
lineup and you know seeing people now
around the Convention Center wearing the
law breakers hoodies and the hats and
everything like that and it's so weird
to see like multiple games and IPs I've
been instrumental in like you know I
still see people crimson Omen shirts and
now I'm seeing them finally starting to
see the character 4-week oh well not the
character the branding that we called
EDS oh it's kind of a you know unhappy
smiley face with like the bullet hole
yeah and so it's we originally had this
kind of lb with a circle for lawbreakers
and just really didn't resonate and then
one of our artists came up with this
cool graphic to kind of put on the
screen when he died and then we were
looking at that like that's really
sticky and even that rohad on our
amazing studio communications manager he
had some swag made up for the
influencers I do hate that term where it
was these awesome vans and actually has
the dead so on the side and it just it
looks like something that you would just
see like I don't even like in a great
little boutique II kind of shoe shop
right yeah so I mean it's one thing
about games you have to have the
marketing and the branding and that's
what makes it sticky and hopefully step
three profit yeah oh no no no that I
mean if you compare yourself to where
you were like when you're releasing
Gears of War social media wasn't really
a thing back then influencers were
really yeah exactly but now you've got
like this constant sort of people
telling you every day what they think is
that like is it more pressure now like I
wouldn't innocent I say you have to be
more open with them because fans expect
more you do you do there's there's
people that I know like Greg Miller and
he has his kind of funny and whatnot he
does a great job with that and I one day
I'd you know for shits and giggles I
went to his Twitter feed because he's
got a great great following he's very
interactive and whenever possible a
person like Greg or somebody who's
good at social media it provided the
person you know talking to them on
Twitter's and being a dick you know they
reply to almost everybody and I'm like I
have enough down time occasionally
throughout the day like like the mode we
ran with shipping the game if I were to
create more work for the team it's just
gonna create like it's gonna get shot
down by the producers cuz they're in
ship mode I am focusing on helping out
with like what role tends going to be
and beyond what the future of the game
is as a live product but I could
actually spend a little bit of time and
start replying more and once you'd reply
they're just like they don't know that
there's a real human on the other end of
their phone or computer then I call me
[ __ ] you replied nor even just the power
of a like like you know this I can't
remember offhand but there's like some
celebrity I was a fan of and I said
something about you know love you and
whatever it was a fairly high level
celebrity and whoever you know I think
they ran their own account they liked it
and like and it's just like senpai
noticed me yeah so sure I would rather
have somebody yelling at me and calling
me a [ __ ] [ __ ] or any number of
things on social media because they care
about the balance of the game that just
being different not play it yeah you
know it just means that they care and so
when the game comes out it's probably
ought to be balanced but that's why it's
going to be a living product we issue
patches updates releases and things like
that and just keep it moving you know
that you're you kick-starting this whole
thing like pushing the boat into the
dock and hopefully just gains momentum
and people are playing and you know it's
one of those things that you know we
want to be more like a rocket League or
warframe in regards to kind of like
sneakily kind of becoming a thing before
anybody realizes it as I was looking at
you know like the top Ted and lists of
games and everyone's excited for Beyond
Good and Evil as they should but the
majority of the things I saw are just
existing brands right yes the spider-man
game looks great
right but it's like it's more spider-man
you know Jess try something a little bit
new and different so then I'm curious
about you know your passion specific to
lawbreakers because you've talked about
where how you want to develop as a
creator more or less but what is it
about lawbreakers that you've really
identified with and really you know
what's kept you going with this game to
keep your passion so I am impatient to a
fault
I hate repeating myself and I'm very
much just go go go and it drives my wife
crazy because she's from New Orleans
where it's just kind of like we'll get
that when we get there and then we'll
have red beans and rice listen it all
thought all that right and I'm just like
[ __ ] that we're getting their point A to
point B which is why whenever I visit
New York City I love it because New
Yorkers are just like go go go go go go
which is like kind of the way this game
plays it's like even the slower
characters have ways of kind of fleeing
across the map and with
get jumping and you know the way that
the shift button works at the
juggernauts and can kind of pound down
the ground
it's just verb after verb after verb
after verb of what am i doing and that
all changed together all these
interesting ways to kind of create this
really like honestly batshit experience
whereas you know I had to sit down a
couple months ago with the art team
because there's times using Nvidia
shadowplay trademark where I hit alt of
10 because likes a fight would happen
and I'd be like what the hell just
happened here like I just I have no idea
where the objective was I have no idea
who or what killed me like we need to
spend a couple months and just dial back
the bloom you know like I don't want the
game to really be cinematic ish you know
I'm not gonna try the only way I want
somebody to cry in this game is if it
was a million dollar tournament
eventually and really pump up the
clarity because there's already so much
going on at the game and we did a pass
at it and the game really really got to
a good point where it's still pretty
crazy but you can generally have a
pretty good idea what's going on even in
the worst case scenario so that's that's
kind of where I'm at with it it's just
show me the verbs show me the action you
know I always say what's more important
story or gameplay and I say the story of
the gameplay we've had moments where we
found out that you know one assassin can
grapple to another assassin on the same
team who could grapple to a merit of
Maverick and just kind of you the three
of them can just kind of like fly
through the map in like three seconds
and there's gonna be so many things
people gonna find when the game shifts
that were they going to have to you know
the course correct and adjust
yeah or make it unfucked so sounds like
a high skill level that sort of leads to
the question of you know competitive
play I've realized that in many ways I
had this epiphany today and I said this
in an earlier interview we may have very
well made the Dark Souls of shooters
that's a claim it is well I'm partially
responsible for like or in a roundabout
way games like Dark Souls becoming
popular because you know it's talking to
Dan who's the main designer in the game
and he worked on Killzone and you know
Microsoft and Sony we're all beating on
like you know you need to get the noobs
in there need to make the game go wide
make it easier to get into easier to get
into and like the game wants being
massaged down where it's like if you
play it on the easy setting the game
plays itself I was joke the games
masturbating for lack of a better term
and so we were at the point we're like
core gamers do love a bit of a challenge
I mean within reason it doesn't need to
be completely insane but they do like to
you know they'll step up and when we had
you know influencers you know come play
the game and then they I watch people on
the show floor we're always worried
about onboarding are they gonna be able
to learn the game or they mean
you have a Q and an e abilities and then
you have everything's different on shift
and then each character has different
health and they move differently and we
just didn't do the same archetypes that
other shooter character based games do
with the bow guy and then the the gnome
with you know the turret or the the
classic medic would then put the noodle
that heals people we did our own things
and so I was like I gonna learn it and
after 15 minutes people are just like
just zipping around the map the first
thing players do when you hand them the
keyboard or in Mouse or controller is
they hit every button it's like okay
show me my verbs and then they after a
few minutes they pick that up they try
the next one before you know if they're
all just sipping around learning it and
hopefully uh you know though other
people will see the art types that we've
kind of forged with this game and you
know maybe be inspired by it kind of
like every game now is covering it yeah
do you feel like modern shooters are way
more hand holding than they used to be
they are not like I said I'm partially
responsible for because it's like yours
it's like press a to take cover it goes
back to that egoraptor video that was
amazing where it's talking about why
Mega Man was so great because Mega Man
just kind of taught you like oh that
person has a charged shot what if I hold
my button oh I can do that too and it
would drop you in a pit you like you
know hey get out of the pit and then you
learn how to kind of like wall jumping
it out as opposed to you know the
example the egoraptor use a snake snake
for SI to jump and it's a get out of
there all that does is interrupt the
player and we do have kind of a very
bare-bones tutorial mode where you can
kind of jump in and kick around and
shoot dummy robots and kind of get to
know the game in little text boxes that
explain everything for those who really
want it I mean I have a theater
background I was a drama nerd in high
school and I always say practice your
lines before you go onstage it's funny
because I'm watching you like I ball in
the game and it's like what I don't know
if it's just me but I think we've made
something very watchable I catch myself
even you know I'll go to you know get a
refill of water and walk by the play
test lab and they'll be hooting and
hollering having a session and I'll just
find myself just there going yeah like
10 minutes later I'm like I didn't get
the hell back to work and for me you
know the everybody always asks is this
game gonna be an eSport you go to do
sport like I was I tweeted like you know
III hadn't even started yet I wanted to
stab somebody says that word it's like
we're gonna do a 4k virtual reality East
fourth roguelike elements like that's
pretty much the ultimate smoke chasing
like kind of animation that you can come
up with and it's like I don't know you
know like one of the games I think might
have a shot initially just saying
they're in eSports as quake champions
because quake is quake and quake is
evergreen right we all know quake is a
great game
for competitive and it'll do well and
they're throwing a million dollars at it
good more power to them other games that
are just completely new and they're like
yeah we're going to do this I'm like
good luck I've seen people try it before
you got to start with a solid great game
that provides a lot of tension that's
fun to watch and then build a great
community around that hopefully not a
toxic one and then find some of the
proper partners and actually start
getting brackets and structure and
funding in there because if you have the
eyeballs that's when people care look at
the cuz that's what the money shows up
right yeah it's you know impressions
right but publishers chase these things
right they don't always know so I'm
guessing that next on is doing a pretty
good job of not cramming that down your
throat it's not we're just I mean we are
full-on focused and just getting the
game out the door August 8th $29.99 and
by the way we just announced the dead so
deluxe edition which is has some really
unique awesome skins you may want
that's for 39.99 but totally optional
yeah but not $60 damn it right it's pet
peeve of mine yeah next one's been
really good as a pub partner the one one
of the many things that I do like about
them and then no publishers perfect
there's always something it's like drive
you crazy there are things that drove me
crazy about Microsoft there things that
drove arjan and the Killzone team crazy
about Sony it's the fact of the matter
they didn't tell me like what kind of
game to make they never said like oh
well we saw a study that says like girls
with blue hair are popular so you need a
girl that's blue hair that's a weapon
because that's cool like guilty gear
like it wasn't like we're like oh like I
played this game last night that has
this crafting system so now you need to
do this you need to do that like
continue to change the direction because
the more the boat changes direction it
never actually gets anywhere and so I
was defiant and like this is the game I
want to make the team then took it and
kind of made it their own and now here
we are where as you know the game really
feels like it has this this sense of
like crazy flow and then it's weird for
me because I had worked on gears for so
long when I was stop and pop right this
game is just non-stop go go go like
you're flowing through the environment
even with the heavier characters and
like that's one thing you know the
elephant in the room of course is the
800-pound gorilla of overwatch because
overwatch is a damn fine game you know I
mean I always tell people I made Farah
my wife means mercy it's gorgeous
Blizzard's character designs or maybe
it's a great two characters that work
together as well exactly exactly and you
know well I just I like rocket launchers
and I like being vertical yeah it was
funny because there is a
a short video of like I think it was
Genji and fara kind of tangling midair
and that went around Kotaku a while back
and like yeah I made that the game you
know and they added a low graph more
they're more welcome to do more than
welcome to do it but their game wasn't
built around it ours was and for me and
what I always tell people is you know
they're a character based game with
abilities that has some guns where a
shooter first and foremost that then has
characters and abilities I think it will
find that when they kind of play with
our gunplay so you know that's one of
those things that also tone-wise you
know the same thing with paladins you
know an overwatch you know paladins is
actually a really good game that's
getting a lot of traction lately but
that art style it's not for me it's you
know I don't know if it's because some
of the Unreal Tournament generation but
I feel I'm vetting the fact that there's
a certain amount of battlefield Halo and
Cod players out there that don't like
that art style right I want something
that looks a little bit more like what
we are and we're not afraid to explode
people into thoughts and actually jib
them right because like when you it's so
gratifying when like you see somebody
that's low health and you're the wraith
after wearing them down with your pistol
and you just do the lunch stab and they
literally explode and you're just like
whoo that was good also even having just
a little bit of blood coming off the
characters and all right and it splats
on the walls when the character ragdolls
it's like it's not because I'm so sort
of Fangoria go around it's for friggin
feedback you know and that's something
that's missing in a lot of these games
that feel like you know they wanted a
cast as wide as possible think overwatch
is that like it's something like 25
million like copies or something like
that so god bless some more power to him
I can have like a fifth of that I'll be
thrilled yeah
are you also recently announcer the
games coming to PlayStation 4 I hate
Xbox how differ much does it differ I
like it
we're gonna if you're gonna mention
overwatch like I can't play the console
version because I play on PC because
it's faster it's more expensive to me
and it feels better yeah are you gonna
have it is the console version of
lawbreakers gonna feel much different
cuz you have to sort of it feels
different always yeah absolutely it's a
keyboard and a mouse is always going to
be a lot quicker and a lot more nimble
than a controller and no matter what you
do um but we do have of course I'm like
friction and adhesion and aim-assist and
whatnot it still feels like wall
breakers but it feels slightly different
hmm but well as we found like everybody
in the company got better and better at
the game it it gets fairly close to the
craziness of the PC so I'd say it's
about 85 percent as crazy
so it's pretty close but honestly it may
be one of those things that if the
craziness of the PC version is a bit
much for you it's a tiny bit dial back
on PlayStation 4 yeah and so yeah that
was the elephant in the room when I was
joking those Xbox and so like Xbox
fanboys getting really salty
yeah really you tell us yeah in general
I respect I don't know it's just it was
one of those things maybe it's because I
haven't mean I worked on the PlayStation
game in awhile but you know they seem to
be fine not enough its Xbox in
particular but because PlayStation has
such a lead this generation and I think
Microsoft will catch up I mean I caught
up with Phil Spencer last night we
talked in like a let's talk you know
like who knows but it's like this was
not a situation of I don't like Xbox
because some of the fans feel betrayed
that Xbox built you who you are and I'm
right yeah look I get your view have
feelings that's cool but this is a
[ __ ] business yeah and I have 65
people many with families who need to
feed those families and keep the lights
on and when we look at hedging our bets
and the install base right now it made
sense to do PC and PlayStation first put
a little rocket League action there
maybe and kind of coast off the you know
both of them being in the zeitgeist the
Sim Sim ship date and we're not really
not Xbox you know maybe out of you know
once the team takes a vacation catches
some air in the games like hopefully a
living product with new roles and new
modes and new maps we do some awesome
version for Scorpio or Xbox X Oh X
whatever the hell they called it I think
it's the misconception as well that
people think oh you're making it for one
console why call you immediately put it
on the other one right well yeah it's
there was some I think it's a gaff post
were they talking about just putting
multiplayer in a game just like flip
that switch you dry today and I'm just
sitting here going doing that the car
like phase right because it's like it's
a miracle that games ever ship yeah it's
a miracle that we all don't strangle
each other and stab each other in the in
the studio but like before we ship in
it's a miracle that you know more
marriages aren't ruined in this business
I've seen it happen firsthand and you
know we were at the point with the team
and in crunch mode where we had some
official crunch periods but there's a
lot of like you know not official crunch
periods but people were voluntarily
working the extra hours and I think the
product you know the end result the the
polish really kind of shows through
there and you know there's a lot of
little things that we were able to have
time for in the game it's talking about
you know Unreal Tournament recently
whereas in Unreal Tournament when you
start walking you go fully to full speed
then when you stop you immediately stop
whereas if you think about the quake and
Team Fortress 2's movement he actually
is a slight bit of a ramp three-quarters
of a second when you stop you glide a
little bit and implement implementing
that a game help the movement feel that
much better but then when you add that
in with Moulton with variable gravity
and then it's the fact that you can
maintain your momentum if you jump a
little bit kind of like a little mini
tribe skiing you know leaping into a low
grab kind of blind firing landing
jumping and kind of moving out and
gliding and there's just really amazing
sense of almost like mini pogo sticking
throughout the map which varies
depending on the character and what
their abilities movement are and then as
well as the kind of stickiness of walls
Unreal Engine 4 is code by default if
this is my character going against the
wall and you hit the wall you kind of
get that kind of like stickiness and I
worked with our programmer Nathan to
make sure it was super smooth so the
only time you even stopped is if you're
completely perpendicular running into
the wall otherwise it just automatically
just kind of glides you along and same
thing with backing along the wall so you
get that kind of like serpentine
movement throughout the levels and this
is the little things these are little
things that framerate that a lot of
people don't necessarily think like
developers sweat but this is the stuff
for me that separates good from great
and any same thing with framerate we
decided to do PlayStation 4 and PC
players work this is going to ruin the
PC version I'm like we had a week where
during our art meetings where we usually
show off on Fridays what all the artists
and animators and whatnot have been
working on effects folks and the art the
the environment team just put up a
PlayStation logo on one Friday because
for the last few weeks like they've just
been optimizing the levels for
PlayStation to get PlayStation to 60
because go 60 or go home 30 frames sucks
like and then the holds 24 frames the
cinematic is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard
so for us 60 on PlayStation plays PS pro
but also on PC if you have a good rig
like we want to optimize the levels on
ps4 so it runs better on the PC yeah so
it's kind of like a like a
mutually-beneficial type of situation
but I just I need like 144 or so like if
the game goes below 100 frames I start
yelling especially considering it so
fast and so twitch twitch base that it's
like away I just go mad and I just like
I think about other games especially
shooters now that are 30 and I'm just
like nope I can't I just become a
framerate snob I can't help it so a game
you're obviously very close to one
you're you you're doing everything you
can to make the game that you want do
you then find yourself playing the games
at you ship after the fact like are you
going to play lawbreakers once it's done
well I mean I certainly hope so I mean
it's still fun for me even after damn
near three years of working on right
like in the last year's when it really
kind of crossed that threshold what
happens in our test lab is we don't
formalize the test that often so what
happens is the QA lead or any of our
testers take the both the bullhorn the
megawatt megaphone and they go you know
testing and up in the lab and y'all
sudden it sounds like Christmas morning
we're here all the feet and what happens
is like you know people who don't get in
the 10 seats they're just like oh man I
guess we'll go back to my desk and work
on when I was working on and you can't
fake that yeah and for me I had this
amazing moment with our last beta where
the beta was going on and my
sister-in-law was visiting and she's
actually I was hanging out with us at
the JW Marriott Lobby on a few matter
she's hilarious and so my wife my
sister-in-law and then we partied up and
then my brother-in-law from Louisiana
hopped on that was just four of us and
some random person hopped in and he's
like hi guys really hi we're family and
we were just playing on all the servers
and just having a blast together and
it's really one of those things that you
know it's fun if you play it alone but
with friends as you know it's always
more fun yeah do you ever like find
yourself looking at a game that you've
finished and say damn it's not actually
finished like there's always something
left named true art isn't to finish -
sure yeah Bandhan right now with games
as service you know like well the point
of when you ship a game as a developer
it's actually can be a little depressing
yeah where it's like oh my god bill bill
bill bill bill okay now it's out not
what and so usually is like okay now we
got to scramble to do some dumb DLC to
charge people for and second second you
know separate our servers and everything
like that but now it's like you know
when the game comes out we'll have the
nine rolls 18 characters but I already
know what class rolled ten plays like
and I when I'm going to be playing in
the wild I'm going to be missing you
know roll ten yeah and when roll tens
rolled in the game roll 11 will be
played internally and so when I play the
wild I'll be missing that one and so it
provided people like the game give us
you know the 29 or $39.99 and support it
you know check out a little like you
know cosmetic loot crate's and things
like that we can keep supporting the
game maybe even you know continue to
have any maps arenas and whatnot and
then maybe even eventually make a second
game mmm cuz I already have other ideas
did you find then before probably sign
of Nexen did you already have the idea
for law breakers or did you and did you
present that to them and then well so
what I did was on
we call it the bake sale um I you know
though everybody knows the story well
whether or not I was retired you know I
took a year and a half and I got after a
year I got bored and then I kind of
formulated that idea by reading you know
sci-fi books by the pool and whatnot you
know it was one of those things that I
was like okay I have this ideas forming
out of this variable gravity and it has
to be a shooter you know what happens if
you fire a gun or a rocket launcher and
modify gravity and just from that core
everything started kind of modifying out
of that and so then I took I had this
like leather-bound book you know the one
you could buy like a book store that
kind of looks like it's fancy but it's
just oh like a moleskin yeah yeah like
some hipster at a coffee shop whatever
and I start right now and all sorts
ideas and just stupid sketches and
everything like that and I went around
and met with EA Activision Ubisoft they
flew my wife and I to Paris to kind of
like you know hang out and get to know
them a little bit and pitch and I'd go
into this meeting a little bit cocky to
be fair and I put the book down I'd be
like I want to make another billion
dollar IP and then ultimately you know I
heard as with every publisher I'd
compare notes with my friends in the
business and they'd be like don't go
with them because I heard this that and
the other and then going don't go with
them and then you know next one came out
of left field and I'm like art writer
they make maplestory yeah and they
wanted to make a Western game and I'm
like we don't get much more of a Western
developer than myself and so when you
look at with lawbreakers is very much
what I hope a Western game but also you
know surgically made it kind of
hopefully expand to a larger market with
characters like Toki who's Korean and
Fang is uh Taiwanese so when you look
back in your career and now with
lawbreakers what do you want your
lasting legacy to be do you think you've
hit it yet or do you think it's
something in the future that you want to
be remembered for I mean I'll never be
thought of is the will right type of mad
genius you know I've honestly for lack
of a better term it because I hate what
he's done with the Transformers
franchise I maybe Michael Bay in his
heyday you know like going back and you
know watching the island or some of
those other movies that he did that were
really good before he got CG like the
rock you know like once the seat once he
really started going full CG zone
Michael Bay's movies just really went
into the [ __ ] and so it's like
transformers the last what's going on
like there's like night
Trent what I don't even I quit when
Devastator had testicles um oh yeah I
missed that one yeah it was uh he was
climbing up the Pyramids of Giza and he
had these two wrecking balls it was just
yeah um anyway so childhood franchise
ruined but I imagine would be something
like that but maybe a little bit of like
a David Fincher sorry I hate to use the
film analogy because I'm you know I've
always gone my own path I guess you know
like I'm not Miyamoto but I'm not well
right and I'm not Gabe Newell I'm just
me and I make fun cool shooting
explosion games alright Ferb's well
thank you so much for joining us I doing
it remind the audience again about
one-nil break is finally out it's coming
out on August 8th 29.99 out of that $60
multiplayer Olli [ __ ] that seems to
happen there is a 39:9 edition with more
skins that are really cool called dead
zone edition we were reopening the
closed beta on June 28th for two days
but then we're doing our full rise up
open beta on the 30th if you guys have
seen anything about the game if it
looked you piques your interest at all
you know you just download it on the
30th give it a go try its little try it
you might like it
awesome oh thank you so much for joining
us guys make sure you stay tuned are we
talking about destiny - right up next